there steve kaufman here today i'm going
to talk about
my two most recent languages
uh which are russian and czech
uh so let's start with russian i think
probably i started five years ago and if
russian has proven anything to me it is
the fact that learning a language
is a long long road but an enjoyable
road because you never get to the end of
it so you know if it ended i'd be
unhappy so i've been at it a long time
uh
so let's trace why did i even start with
russian you know this was as i say five
years ago i spoke at that time i guess
uh eight or so uh languages
i had had a brief fling with korean but
i i discontinued because the content
that i could find wasn't very
interesting
i will go back to korean one day
um
so i began by buying you know the usual
teach yourself
and i i think you know for the cost of a
beginner course
buy two or three cover the same basic
stuff in three or four different
directions so i think i bought teach
yourself
living language whatever i could find
down at the bookstore and just go
through them as i've said before mostly
listening and reading and acquiring
vocabulary and skimming the grammar
explanations
then that was about the time we we made
russian available at link
so we have a ten store a series of
stories uh
you know uh who is she for example is 26
episodes long
uh in all the different languages and so
i had one at that time i had a russian
employee
in fact still have and um had the uh in
fact we had two russian employees and so
i had two versions made of of uh
who is she translated into russian and
then the original recording the sound
quality wasn't all that good so i had it
done again and i mean i listened to that
so many times and i
painstakingly went through the uh the
texts
at uh
you know what link
and i would think within about two or
three months i started out with i wanted
to get at tolstoy and and there were two
reasons why i
i decided to learn russian one was
because everyone said you can't learn
russian with your approach and my
approach being one of sort of ignoring
not ignoring the grammar but treating
the grammar lightly grammar light words
heavy
uh so well you can't do that with
russian so that was a challenge and the
other thing was i have always enjoyed
reading reading tolstoy in particular in
english so i wanted to read it in the
original i thought that would be an
amazing thing to be able to do
so the first novel that i went at was
the kreutzer sonata i should have
brought a copy of the book it's a
smaller it's you know it's not like uh
you know war and peace which is two huge
volumes
uh
and i i was able to find
a an audiobook for it and uh
trying to think where i bought that but
i think a major um sort of um impetus
for my russian was that we had business
in regal latvia
and so when i went to la riga i
went to find a russian bookstore and i
just helped myself to tons of audio
books including an audio book on the
kreutzer sonata so it's shorter
and i can remember in those days uh you
know link didn't work as well as now and
it would three or four seconds for each
to save each word and everything was
clunkier and more difficult and i still
did it
and i
you know found more and more uh
audio books and and typically these are
all classics i can remember reading
you know the station master's daughter
by pushkin
i must have listened to that i don't
know 10 times i was at that time i was
training
for um a ski race in sweden called the
vasa lopez where i would have had to run
90 kilometers and i trained
i don't know how many hours but i i put
in about 400 kilometers of training of
cross-country skiing a lot of that was
done listening to russian
um
the uh station master's daughter i don't
know how many times i listened to it
and uh yeah so you know i mean i'm
talking about
like audiobooks you know
this was one of my favorites that i did
later on was uh yama by cuprin
which is just a phenomenal story and i
listened to on and on didn't half
understand it
my wife would get mad at me i'm playing
golf i'm listening to russian you know
president
you know warren at least crime and
punishment
here is the cap capitan
this is the captain's daughter no i'm
confusing two stories here one was the
captain's daughter which i also listened
to and the other was the uh
postmaster's daughter or whatever i
can't remember what they called it but
anyway i listened to that here is uh
bogakov you know sabacces
dr zhivago by pasternack
and one of my absolute favorites here
was a a radio presentation of aside
you know by turgenie fathers and sons
master margarita brothers karamazov
anna karenina
you are in peace and of course along
with that i did my reading and fairly
soon
i was able to read like i read this book
by edward rodzinski on stalin which is
amazing
but i got lots more of that kind of
stuff i haven't read them all if i find
books i buy a bunch because you never
know when you're gonna when you're gonna
you know find the time to read them or
you may not find them again so that was
probably the first year or two i made a
couple of youtube videos you can still
find them of me speaking russian after
six months after a couple of years and
so forth and so on
then i remember around august the eighth
2008 i discovered echamaskville and it
just happened to coincide with the
russian georgian war
and so erica must be every day you can
find as i mentioned many times you can
find like 10 or more
new interviews
audio and text for download so i take
the audio and the text i import it into
link all the words and phrases and so
just a constant constant process of
gradually gradually improving i still
make mistakes when i speak russian but i
understand most things uh oh i also went
there's a store here in vancouver called
ruskimir where you can buy the
movie uh you know cds so i bought a
bunch of those
i watched you know irony subby which is
a lovely movie and uh jestoki romance
those are some of my favorites i still
have them
to me videos like i will only watch them
once maybe twice so it doesn't have the
value of the book that i might read and
go back and read again or or audiobooks
for that matter
but once i hit echemoskv i was basically
listening every day
to articles and reading and stuff like
that and throughout the period i think
link has become a little smoother and so
i'm able to cover more ground more
quickly but i've been at it for five
years i still make mistakes there's
still some things i don't understand but
by and large
any interview on echo must be i
understand
most of what they're saying there might
be five percent words there that i don't
know so that's kind of where my russian
is
and so then i decided to go after czech
for several reasons one is the
low-hanging fruit theory of language
learning i know spanish therefore i can
learn portuguese
i put all that effort into learning
chinese characters so i'm gonna learn
japanese and eventually korean
and so i figured i'll go after czech
surprising to me the
grammar the structure of the languages
is very similar
but the vocabulary is not
uh as not as similar as i thought
apparently only 40 of words in check
uh are either the same as or
recognizable as similar to russian so
obviously between even spanish and
italian there is a much greater
similarity
so here again i started out i have
managed to find a teach yourself check
that i bought some years ago i went
through that i started we had yarda and
and uh zdenyak binyak a number of our
members had link who created a bunch of
beginner content i went through all of
that at first it's all a blur
and gradually you know the language just
starts to become clearer and clearer
then i found radio prog
which is a tremendous tremendous
resource it's it is my echo must be it's
different in nature but they have
their uh
daily news items with audio and text for
download but they have and i'm going to
put the links up somewhere in my comment
section but they have a tremendous
collection of audio material you know
karel chopic
um they have a whole history thing which
i'm now going through i can't remember
quite what it's called but it's it's
phenomenal i'll leave the link there
and uh there you can find
uh the audio and the text of the most
recent ones and it's extremely well done
and the quality of the sound
you know when you're listening to a
foreign language is very important uh
and i've discovered i discovered too
that they had uh
an audio uh uh you know downloadable for
free download audiobook of joseph
schworetzky bobby lonski bay cognet's
okay so then i was able to find this
book in victoria there's a czech
bookstore so i ordered this online
uh the audio is doesn't match it you
know word for word but but i'm gonna try
and read through the book
uh and then listen and so you just just
kind of bombarding myself so every day
i'll
you know uh this history uh
thing
which i can tell you what it's called
but uh
minou some you know what was it called
again i can't
remember but
i will tell you uh
where is it now
and
so there i found five texts which i've
imported and i'm slowly going through
them and listening uh go to the health
club here and i'm listening to my uh
you know
tolkie tolkie cesco minolosti
yeah that's all and i've started uh
speaking to uh martin tutors at uh i
think and
i might even record um have a
session tomorrow at nine so i might even
record it and uh
but it's pretty bad my spoken check at
this point is still pretty bad we'll see
how it goes i've been at it for six
months
uh
but enjoying it and it's going much
faster in czech and then in russian
and and i think a because i have russian
so the grammar is less of a less of a
struggle it seems less strange to me
uh and the second thing is that it's
written in latin alphabet so that's more
comfortable uh what else can i say it's
it's uh but i know that uh you know even
in my russian and i still listen to
russian i've downloaded five interviews
i like to listen to victor chanderovich
and uh
he's on today it's fridays i got his
downloaded
and um
what's his name svanitsa
nikolai swanitsa those are some of my
uh you know people i like to listen to
it echo must be so i have to find the
time to listen to them as well as
listening to my check
but
i guess the big message is i i you know
obviously i enjoy doing it not everybody
enjoys learning languages i'd like to do
it in a way that i find enjoyable i try
to move from the beginner text onto
authentic text as quickly as possible
because i find them more interesting
even though it's a bit of a struggle
i'll go back to easier text just to kind
of give myself a little bit of
of confidence i guess
at times it seems that you'll never make
sense of this language uh you know in
czech they say things differently from
from russian they have uh you know
i won't go through the details but it's
different so you gotta get used to it
you just gotta get used to it and at
times it seems like you're not gonna get
used to it but i know from experience
that i will get used to it and i think
that's a big advantage that i have
having done it many many times i know
that i will get used to it and i enjoy
the process and that's another big
advantage a lot of people don't enjoy
the process i enjoy it and of course i
enjoy it much more now that i can
understand a lot certainly in russian
and increasingly so in check uh when i
go after turkish which i intend to do
or even going back to the korean it'll
be
you know a little more work less
pleasure in a way although
you know that pleasure of of taking on a
task which is difficult but which you
know that you're going to be able to get
through so there is that great sense of
satisfaction uh i guess there was this
uh
hungarian-american who spoke of flow in
other words there's a great sense of
satisfaction on taking on something that
is difficult but you know that you can
in fact cope with it
and i think that's perhaps just to
finish off on that i think that's where
a lot of language learners get
frustrated i don't believe i mean yeah
you get better at it the more languages
you learn but i think we can all learn
and too many people get frustrated too
many people get hung up about you know
they forget i forgot this i forgot that
and and a lot of people get into you
know okay like i'm having this
discussion on my blog like when do you
know if you know a word who cares you
know you can't say you know it unless
you can use it at will or at least you
should make a distinction between
recognizing it in a context and being
able to recognize it away from a contest
it doesn't matter the more exposure you
have to these words gradually
gradually the scope of their meaning
what they mean
understanding them away from a context
eventually using them it's it's a
gradual process you don't need to worry
too much about trying to categorize
these words how many do i know we have
these statistics that link because it
motivates people it confirms to that
you're moving to you that you're moving
forward but you didn't get too hung up
about what it all means the major um for
me motivation is in the content is
finding that you know six months ago
there is no way that i could have
understood anything in this book and now
about an hour or two a day of working
and listening and reading and so forth
i'm going to be able to pick my way
through this
and listen to it
and gradually it'll make more and more
sense to me and then i'm going to be
working on check on link and increasing
my vocabulary and
many year from now i'll be all i know is
i'll be a lot better than i am now
whether i'll be fluent by anybody's
definition or b1 b2 c1a2 doesn't matter
to me at all because the enjoyment is
the task and it's a task that constant
constantly progresses towards a feeling
of greater and greater mastery over the
language
so there you have it i did my two most
recent languages
russian and czech i hope this was
helpful and hopefully it encourages you
to keep going when sometimes you think
you're not making any progress